you got to know bowie very well too
which is no you didn't because i thought
that bowie was interested in comedy yeah
he became upset
and wanted to know about stephen wright
it absolutely came to you no this here's
what happened so i was doing
uh i was co-hosting this show and it was
a comedy show over in london but it also
ran on the comedy channel which turned
into comedy central here right it was
called london underground here in
paramount city over there but i would
bring over
comedian friends of mine to as the
american comics and they would have a uh
usually a british music act as well
right you know there was some great acts
like shane o'connor was there elvis
costello was there and usually what
happened with the with the musical acts
is that they didn't really hang around
with the comedians none of us were
famous yet right you know what i mean so
they just came and did a sound check and
then when it was time for them to go on
camera and sing their song they sang
their song and then they split
so i saw bowie was like whatever the
fourth week yeah and what stage was
bowie and was he like uh he was tin
machine oh this is 1991 and i'm a bowie
freak so i was like you know what i
don't give a [ __ ] what happened i got to
meet bowie at some point in this
afternoon right even if i if they tell
me not to go in an area and he's it's
such a weird thing like you you don't
you don't want to be doing that it's
kind of creepy but you can't help
yourself and now you got an opportunity
i was gay for both hey go ahead hey we
all work and i think my wife would
understood right so uh you had to go it
was an old west end theater in in london
so you had to go outside to smoke in an
alley so smoking introduces you to more
people so we i went outside to smoke a
cigarette and i was still in the process
of trying to figure out like when am i
going to meet him how am i going to do
it i didn't know he was in the building
yet right and i looked up and he was
literally right here right in front of
you little alley he's right here and
he's like hey man you got a light and i
howard i swear to god i i panicked but i
was also like i've got to say my stuff
because it's not going to last long so i
i lit his cigarette and before as soon
as the cigarette came out his mouth
before i could say anything he went
so you're friends because uh stephen
wright and gulthwaite had already made
it he goes you're friends with stephen
wright i heard you went to college with
him and i was like uh oh yeah and he's
like you know i met him but i don't know
what he's really like what's he really
like right so i was like wow i'm in with
bowie i'm so [ __ ] in i go he's and
he's hot for steven ryan yeah i'm like
steven steven i had to have to have that
he was like interesting now what about
bobcat goldfish because i you know i had
him flown in for one of my gigs and so
i'm like bobcat i knew bobcat
and then as soon as i finished telling
him the bobcat thing he goes very
interesting somebody goes all right i'll
set you mr bowie and he goes all right
mate see you later put the cigarette
walks away never i see him on stage that
night never see the man again that was
the whole encounter i was like you
[ __ ] and what was your agenda
though what was your real i mean what
did you say dude right like your music
stones you know you beatles i mean
that's how i survived until [ __ ] punk
rock in the clash and the ramones came
in that's right by the way the most
boring [ __ ] thing you could say to
david bowie what everybody else says oh
my god you're my hero yeah great yeah
great beginning yeah i wrote a song
about that yeah